Um, so you, you go to
this one destination,
you a, you shoot this black Jack.
Will you hooked immediately?
Yes. Really. It was not about
his fishing part. Actually,
I was still traumatized in the water.
I still had panics attacks
when I was in the water and um,
but I fell in love to second.
I arrived to shore and we barbecue the
fish on a beach and I was like, okay,
this is,
this is for me.
That's the same exact thing that happened
to me when I went deer hunting when we
were,
me and my friend Brian Cowen and Steve
Rinella and Dan Dody were cooking this
deer meat by a fire. And I was like,
this is the greatest thing ever.
This is, the meat was so fresh because
it was like from an animal that was,
you know, literally killed hours ago.
And then we're eating it by, by the fire.
I was like, this is, I'm going to do this
forever. This is the greatest thing ever.
Primal, right? It is. It's
you, you, you feel, you felt,
what I was told people is that, you
know, when you live in a big city,
like when I've never
experienced that before,
I've never felt that I was part
of the ecosystem whatsoever.
Right?
And then all of a sudden I've been putting
myself into water when I'm surrounded
by sharks are big fish or different
things. And I'm like, wow,
we're actually not in top
of the food chain at all.
There's a lot of stuff on above us. I
can't kill us. And it's, it's, it's,
it's caring. It's humbling. And I think
as a person, you have to experience that.
You have to,
you have to put yourself out of your
conference old to understand that you need
to respect what's around you. You could
tell me 10 years ago, ah, you have G. Dot.
Fish because it's baffled DRM. And I'd
be like, yeah, yeah, sure buddy. Right?
And then you see an airplane,
you're like, Ooh, that looks good.
Then it's fine and this.
But then when you in a water and you see
what's going on and you see the a spa,
you've been diving for five years old,
southern is empty,
then it makes you understand that,
you know,
we actually have a very strong
impact and it's, it's our job to,
to understand and, and, and respect it.
We're where we're at.
Where did it go? System,
which just the one that we're
the smartest one. Sometimes
we're the only ones that are
consciously aware of our actions and the
repercussions. Yes. Our actions.
What, when, when you're,
you know,
first experiencing this your first time,
eat in this feeling of connectedness
and freedom and just being a part of the
ecosystem,
did you imagine that some or know that
this could be your life and your job?
Not at all. I've, I've, I've, I've
never been hiking, I'm not a big fan of,
I've never used to be a big fan
of the outdoors. I'm, I've, I've,
I don't go to the gym and
exercise. I go to the gym, no, no,
that basically don't eat anything.
And then all of a sudden I was living in
London and the Nice apartment with two
dogs and a nice car and all of a sudden
I was in fricking Africa being in a Bush,
getting catching my own food and sharing
would villages or had nothing eat.
And it was like, okay, well this is,
how did that happen?
Like how did you go from this one trip?
Um, I got invited to film a documentary
and food sourcing and I was like, okay,
I'm going to try it.
And I fell in love with it and
the second I went back to London,
I remember sitting in my desk and
be like, she, no way I can do that.
There's no way I can keep doing that for
rest of my life. And everybody taught,
I was completely crazy.
I sold everything I and I just left,
I moved away and I,
I have like maybe two suitcases of
stuff for the past three years and
I was reading somewhere where they were
going to do an interview on you and they
decided not to.
They're going to feature you in something
with a decided not to because of
concerns for the depletion of
fish in the ocean, and I said,
that is one of the dumbest fucking things
I've ever heard because the impact of
someone like you, what you're doing,
you for your own personal consumption,
taking a fish a day or whatever you're
getting for your own personal consumption
is negligible in comparison to all these
people that are probably writing these
articles that are going to buy Sushi
from commercial fishermen. They're there,
they're buying fish from the store
that's wrapped in Saran wrap there and
they're, they're completely out of
touch. I don't mean your intouch,
you're as in touch as you can get,
but to think that somehow or another
you're doing something evil because you
take photos of it and
put it on your Instagram.
What was that one you had this amazing
photo from a couple of days ago with you
with is this big fish?
It was so fresh and you,
you guys were eating pieces of it.
He had cut a chunk of out
of the out of its tail.
Yes. That was in Thailand? Yeah,
Paquette. Paquette actually, yeah.
We'll just went with this
friend of ours would his family,
and we just went off for today and we
went spearfishing when my phone would
caught a fish and,
and the guy was super happy.
He cut it right on the spot and all the
kids were just picking on it and it was,
they were so excited.
The second year he came,
the second day came that the
boat arrived back to the island.
He just went and grabbed the fish and
they were trying to take pictures.
It was super cute.
What,
what was the argument for not,
what was the piece that they were trying
to put you in where they pulled you out
of it?
What was that about?
Oh, that story is, it's still
getting me pretty angry.
She'll basically where I was speaking
at a woman empowerment conference in New
York last May. And then when I
was actually in Thailand, the,
the woman that is organizing it calls
me and she's like, oh look Valentine.
Like I need to talk to you about
something. And it's, you know,
it's a little touchy. I'm
like, what? She's like, well,
one of her sponsors said that if
you speak at a conference thing,
gonna withdraw their
participation and the conference,
what was the sponsor and
the Wall Street Journal,
The Wall Street Journal.
And I'm like, and she said, yeah,
do you feel like that's your lifestyle
is in align with ocean preservation?
And that's, and she said something,
she didn't say it directly,
but she said,
and you know me,
I don't mind that you have pictures
and a beanie seat. I'm like,
what do you mean should have my beanie?
You, sorry, my Burkini was not clean.
Like what do you want
from [inaudible] beach?
When am I supposed to wear
swimming? I'm swimming, you know,
wear your bathing suit.
You mean
your high heels? You know,
being an Insta model,
you're wearing a bathing suit and
there's nothing wrong with that either.
But you're wearing a bathing suit
because you're actually in the water.
Exactly. I'm not in Mykonos next
year. Fricking pool. I'm in, I'm in,
I'm in Africa on a beach
when it's like 110 degrees,
what am I supposed to Campbell's Arion.
Exactly.
Respect.
So,
so I mean,
what did you say to them?
Well that's Wall Street Journal.
That is so crazy. You know what?
And I get it from their perspective,
it's a bullshit argument.
But from their perspective, it's just
about optics. It's about how it looks.
That's all it is.
And if they go there and people love to
get outraged about something and if they
go there and then they go
to your Instagram and they
find pictures of you with
fish, they're like, well this girl's
cleaning out the ocean all by herself.
She killing home.
You would have to be really good.
I mean, have you ever seen a commercial
fishing boat? What they do? Yes. Yeah.
Most people haven't.
Jamie CV,
you could pull off the horrific affects
of commercial net fishing because,
uh, if you find a video, we
can watch a clip of the video.
It's crazy when you see the sheer
volume of fish that they pull out of the
ocean.
And when you realize there's countless
numbers of these boats and essentially
pretty much unregulated and
no one's watching them and
they're doing it all over
the world. I mean there's areas
where you're not allowed to fish,
but overall it's nothing like the way
we treat wild mammals or wild birds.
The way we treat wild mammals,
especially in North America is
they're very closely monitored.
Their numbers, their populations.
We make sure that it,
unless it's an invasive species like
wild pigs, I, here we go, this is,
this is awful.
They take this gigantic net,
they circle all these fish and
then when they're pulling them in,
you get to see the sheer volume
so you as they get close.
But that's, that's, that's one of
the smoother way to commercial fish.
Frances ready big on on trawlers
and it's two kilometers wide net.
That is actually,
it's,
it's scraping the bottom completely
destroying every store in the coral.
This is his shocks on each side.
This is actually a,
a fairly mild one and it looks like
they're getting these little tiny fish but
me, you could find it folks if you
wanted to go and Google it online,
but that is the issue
too, right? That these,
these go all the way to the bottom and
they destroy anything that they touch.
Like the whole, the bottom of
the ocean just gets dragged in.
All the coral gets destroyed.
It's this extremely destructive, but it's
what, what, that's how you get Sushi.
There's so much the fish industry,
it's not even necessarily
how you get Sushi.
It's how you get Sushi so
damn cheap. Right? But it's,
it's by Deloitte. If we keep doing that
is literally going to be no fish very,
very, very soon. But then how do you
explain that? And Canada, you know,
allowed to spearfish what and you have to
release most of the fish. You run rail.
There's a lot of your stories.
Most of the fish you rod and reel.
Yeah. In Canada. Like you'd like
the stripers try Beth. And how many,
how many can you get a day straight past
like one a day or something like one a
day. Spearfishing, one a day.
And, and the US site and Canada.
You not even in touch anything you want.
Can't use spear phishing Canada because
the Anglers Association in Canada,
things that were to evil
basically that you're evil. Why?
Because you can actually see
what you're catching. Yeah.
So basically w where did cheaters,
because we can see the fish and I'm like,
how can you be a new
camping chairs on your boat?
Drinking Beers all day telling me that um,
the cheater when I'm working my ass off
diving at like 60 feet to catch my fish
to bring it back. And I Rick, smile
life. I was my life drowning and risk.
My left would shark service my life
would all sorts of things that can happen
and you're telling me drinking you but
wise when you fricking camping chair that
I'm the cheater. I'm sorry, but no.
Well people always want to think that
everybody else is doing it wrong. True.
You know, vegans want to thank people
that eat meat or doing it wrong.
People that eat meat, one of the
things, vegans are doing it wrong.
People fish off a boat.
Want to think that people spearfish,
you're doing it wrong. You'd think
they're probably doing it wrong.
No, I have nothing. Again, catching
you on food as long as you, you know,
respectful would,
would do or you do it.
But there was a big scandal in Florida
for the past years with the red snapper
by example. And it was about, um,
like recursion recreational fishing.
You allowed a certain amount of,
of red snapper and then a season closes
and then when a season closes as an
individual,
my license to fish is gone.
And then he gave it away to the
commercial fishermen and I'm like,
whoa.
So basically you telling me that I'm
not allowed to catch that fish for a few
months because of population is too bad.
But then you given my quota to the
commercial boats that are at catching
hundreds a day. They like, yeah,
no, it doesn't make any sense.
No, it doesn't. Then what?
Most people are not going to spear fish.
Most people are going to fish,
so they don't, you guys
don't have a voice, right.
In terms of like representative voice
comes to creating these laws and
establishing these, these rules.
There's not that many of you
and the food chain. We're
the plankton is, you know,
you had a commercial fishing would very
big, uh, lobbyists, men, a lot of money.
And then you have the Anglo
or juices a little bit.
It's still not super bad because
it's still have big boats,
company and equipment is still, I give
the market which is good enough. Right.
And then you had a spear
fisherman, right? I'm spearfishing.
Men's were not a lot in the world's eye.
I couldn't even tell you how many,
but we're not 100 million
us for fricking sure.
It's probably less spear fisherman.
Then there are bow hunters.
Okay.
That's highly possible.
Yeah,
I would,
I would imagine because it seems more
dangerous and difficult than bow hunting.
It seems like the next level,
it seems like one of the most difficult
things you can do if you want to get
your food,
it's because you're going into an alien
environment and you're holding your
breath. True. But actually the human body,
that's the main argument I
get from people. They tell
me, Oh, I could never do it,
but every, the human body
is actually made to do this.
So there's a thing called
the Mammalian dive reflex,
and this is very present
and aquatic mammals such as
like, it's like a Dolphin's,
your sales and things like that. And the
human have it in a very way, weaker way,
but we still have it.
And so when you emerge
as you face on the water,
your heartbeat is automatically
going to slow down,
especially if the water is colder.
So you bodies,
as you're getting prepared to
hold his breath to catch food,
and that's,
that's a new DNA.
Is it preparing to catch food or is it
just preparing to survive to hold your
breath on the water? Right.
Some reason. I mean, I, I guess,
I guess that was a very successive,
thank you so.